voilà
françaises français vous à qui si
souvent j'ai parlé pour la france sachez
que votre réponse dimanche va engager
son destin parce que d'abord il s'agit
d'apporter à la structure de notre pays
un changement très considérable c'est
beaucoup de faire renaître nos anciennes
provinces aménagé à la moderne sous la
forme de région de leur donner les
moyens nécessaires pour que chacune
règle ses propres affaires tout en
jouant son rôle à elle dans notre
ensemble nationale d'en faire des
centres où l'initiative l'activité la
vie s'épanouissent sur place c'est
beaucoup de réunir le sénat et le
conseil économique et social en une
seule assemblée délibérante par priorité
et publiquement de tous les projets de
loi au lieu d'être chacun de son côté
réduit à des interventions obscur et
accessoires
c'est beaucoup associer la
représentation des activités
productrices et les forces vives de
notre peuple à toutes les mesures
locales et législatives concernant son
existence et son développement
votre réponse va engager le destin
de la france parce que la réforme fait
partie intégrante de la participation qu
exige désormais équilibre de la société
moderne la refuser c'est s'opposer à
cette transformation sociale morale
humaine
faute de laquelle nous irons à de
désastreuse secousses l'adopter
ce faire un pas décisif sur le chemin
qui doit nous mener au progrès dans
l'ordre et dans la concorde en modifiant
profondément nos rapports entre français
votre réponse va engager le destin de la
france
parce que si je suis désavoué par une
majorité d'entre vous
solennellement sur ce sujet capital et
quel que puisse être le nombre l'ardeur
de l'armé de ceux qui me soutiennent et
qui de toute façon détiennent l'avenir
de la patrie ma tâche actuelle de chef
de l'état deviendra évidemment
impossible et je se serait aussitôt
d'exercer les fonctions
alors comment sera maîtrisé la situation
résultant de la victoire négatives 2 ou
ses diverses
disparates et discordantes opposition
avec l'inévitable retour au jeu des
ambitions illusion combinaisons et 13
ans dans les branchements nationale que
provoquera une pareille rupture
au contraire s'il reçoit la preuve de
votre confiance je poursuivrai mon
mandat j'achèverai grâce à vous par la
création des régions et la rénovation du
sénat l'oeuvre entreprise il y a dix
années pour doter notre pays
d'institutions démocratiques adapté au
peuple que nous sommes dans le monde
nous nous trouvons et à l'époque où nous
vivons
après la confusion les troubles et
malheurs que nous avions traversé depuis
des générations
je continuerai avec votre appui de faire
en sorte quoi qu'il arrive que le
progrès soit développée l'ordre assurer
la monnaie défendu la dépendance
maintenu la paix sauvegarder la france
respecte et enfin une fois venu le terme
régulier sans déchirement et sans
bouleversement tournant la dernière page
du chapitre que voici quelques trente
ans j'ai ouvert dans notre histoire
je transmettrai ma charge officielle à
celui que vous aurez élus pour l'assumer
après mois françaises français dans ce
qu'il va advenir de la france
jamais la décision de chacune et de
chacun de vous north a pesé aussi lourd
vive la république vive la france